hello back of this video playing whoo
team are with that no information okay
so we gotta worry about actually that
was stupid I wanted to test something
new ahead automatically played my
variation yet my old Sheeran ok I'm
going to give it another another tribe
my blitz results are good with that with
that weird line they're really okay if
they keep making this mistake for
example we should be age six it's not a
big thing but it slightly in precise
after f6 and 97 you have to move the
bishop again sorry for that my voice is
not on in super good shape got a slight
coal and lots of work and if you teach a
co basically speaking a lot okay so he
allows me to take this this is kind of
surprising it's quite comfortable for
black now already this is why I keep
playing it sometimes why players
absolutely have no idea what to do like
here your blog is already in good shape
no King side is completely safe and he
has no clear plan we should 1c to us
also quite quite a bad piece
yeah I'm probably threatening to take on
a form wow I had anticipated that idea
and I wasn't really sure how we with
this both okay can't even go here okay
93 is the exchange but maybe open up
first and I one day if 93 is even good I
mean it's not bad but I came out i'll
take the exchange the night was a
fantastic piece only five this is why i
was a bit hesitant no idea has no no
attack on anything great that you can do
on the King side ok your own Queen B
seven maybe for Queen B to really not
sure if I should have taken the exchange
I mean probably yes objectively but for
practical play maybe keeping the night
on the board was some was easier
now but he's just falling a party
actually so can take AF for Ruby eight
it's a good thing for me too
just have to be careful that I'm not
bringing my stuff here too far off side
mmm this is this kind of thing okay come
on and let's do it like that but that
bishop was a terrible piece not sure of
naira came I'm two pawns up now and get
the Queen to e5 so it cannot be too bad
but if it was the best thing I have my
doubts okay it splits pretty jacket it's
pretty good I get the Bishop to g5 now
oh yes to get go to the lost ending
ticking I'm just one point up all right
what's too optimistic about the porn
coward funny enough okay so Wow not
cleaning up 649 h5 don't do that
going for Queen F for him
check and I was thinking that night age
six is not helping him but maybe it does
got this check them
check check I don't die still don't see
how it helps them right h6 Queen F for
24 years check on c8 now but he will go
to sea for that could be could be a
problem problem in the end game no not
really but okay I already made life a
bit more difficult than I then I needed
to check
check that's good night you for check
ok
check
check okay so let's go here time where
they don't see a clear winning plan yet
I cannot go here cannot enter with the
king hmm it's not good how to do this
okay I have to go here and see from here
to do it
I don't see a temple down okay now i
cannot win this especially neutral to
time brah our third game drawn yeah I
don't know I'm just an idiot what an
awful game not winning this is
completely completely adjusted you ought
to check and it was from this position
is and okay I could I'm kind of lost for
words here Jack a whatsit world of
course winning for a very long time
check check and also that end game
should win I mean I don't really see why
I didn't see you didn't fire in here
maybe it was something bad here okay one
idea that I didn't see is that I can
just give away the d6 pawn as the engine
points out because now I'm picking up
all the pawns so just the computer line
and this is a complete winner it's
something like that you have to be a
little bit more precise the way I played
it actually this is probably a draw this
is probably a draw
yeah I just played it and completely
idiotic game IAM even taking on t taking
on d oneness completely this is just
idiotic why do i do that i can play
everything here it's got two bad pieces
and i don't have to give stuff back I
can play whatever he can basically
resign this after that that 93 and this
kind of business not winning that such a
game is really unforgivable but one
thing I have to say I just completely
miscounted I was thinking I was two
pawns up and of course I can be I can
just take this which I probably should
have done that makes stuff a lot easier
yeah unbelievable that I didn't try i
already have that problem that has
sometimes relax too much when I think
it's everything winds and then you
sometimes step by step you kind of let
your advanced Windle drown yeah like one
more inaccurate move one more lazy move
and all of a sudden it gets interesting
again and at the end yet this this
fortress and end a draw Wow okay thanks
for watching